okay people joining the live stream this
is a continuing series of meetings about
geographical historical data and let's
see let's just review what we concluded
last time and then keep going actually
what do we think we have concluded this
whole initial section here I think we
had invented okay let me just take a
look here Geographics are a time series
opacity needs to do weighted based on
time span okay proposal for qu and then
Q R okay duration should be expanded to
take a second argument saying what's its
saturation of okay I don't think that's
just shoddy who needs to be contacted
that I think that for the time series
team should only return conflicts that
match the temporal span Roman Empire
okay you stated all okay I'll put of Joe
identify needs to be usable in timeline
plots right okay what doesn't
distribution of a time series of
polygons output so that's part of the
answer discussion about if we should use
these empirical distribution or
something else like weighted data okay I
should be under consideration when they
create these duration of a time series
what should that okay hold on that
there's another thing that term
um ha sorry the the the other thing we
would been talking about which doesn't
seem to have made it on here was the
business about a new form of time series
event series whatever that is what was
that thing we talked about the thing
that is equivalent for a hop from a hold
from left time series right the thing
that doesn't have the fencepost problem
about the beginning and end you know
what I'm talking about
I think we're planning to somehow extend
the beat time series to do that itself
introducing a new object I think at some
point couple of weeks ago you talked
about a data table jekt a story dated
series yes okay and why is that I mean
because a dated series would give a
bunch of intervals right would give the
state of things over a bunch of
intervals right but are you saying that
basically that time series could equally
well take that series of data intervals
and values okay what happens if you okay
all right fine I'm fairly convinced
about that if indeed if indeed we think
that it will always be the case yeah
it's reasonable to just give the data
interval for something there are open
and closed interval questions which you
guys would have to deal with um I mean
go show do you think this is reasonable
if this is a partition of the date line
then we have no problems in a way off
over love's right what about machine
precision and so on oh so that's the end
the case of closure open closed right
interpretation so I think that that
interval already has some
you know decision twee one side open one
side close so that results to see you
yeah exactly
we're planning to have date interval by
default to be closed on the left open on
the right and then we can partition
without overlapping I think we're gonna
need some kind of conformance function
that takes a bunch of data intervals
that don't conform properly and just
knits them in some way I see here's
another case that I think is gonna get
awkward so let's imagine that we have
when I say we have polygons for
historical countries they are granular
eyes by year
okay and then hmm okay look what I
suspect is gonna happen and maybe
somebody can say with respect to
historical polygons don't we have
polygons where you know at the Battle of
Waterloo the polygons changed so to
speak
do we have polygons were on a particular
day they changed or are they only
changing by year we only change in by
year okay do we believe that to be
correct I mean as in is there well this
is now this is now in the in this case I
don't understand history well enough but
go ahead yeah well we have some cases
that where we have when we know their
end date that's the ending date of the
volume and we know it to the day is that
correct yes and sometimes not always but
yes in some cases and just out of okay
this is a history question I mean you
know a battle happens see I don't even
know how this works I mean I you know
when I mean when there's a surrender
treaty one understands the moment when
that treaty is signed well or the Treaty
says in it when certain things will
become effective right but I don't know
what one does I mean what does it even
mean to say my knowledge of of wars is
insufficient to UM do you understand a
question I'm asking is it does even mean
anything to ask what the polygons look
like in other words does it you know
unless there is a sort of legal like
process that happens I don't know that
we could ever possibly know these
polygons anybody want to comment on this
this is a matter of history and we can
we should assume that there will be
different cases his cases in the past in
which we just know an approximation in
cases in recent times in which we know
that our
if indeed it's happening by treaty as
opposed to you know the army is
retreating and therefore you know and
it's completely unclear what that means
for the border of the country I mean
there are certain defined border marks
throughout history with primary
documents you know like Caesar saying I
took this town you know if one believes
right well you know archaeology
generally accepted fair enough fair
enough
but I mean so so do we think okay but
but in that case
I mean like to the day we wouldn't know
back at that time right we don't even
know what dead of week day of the week
the Ides of March when Caesar was
assassinated were was do we I mean so we
obviously don't know we couldn't even
get that even if we wanted to we don't
have enough calendar information going
back that far
to get it to the day it's a true
statement
very rarely correct that is correct yes
very rarely would we actually be able to
pinpoint a day and usually it's
confirmed because there was some sort of
like eclipse that happened or some right
right right right right but I don't even
know in the case of you know Brian on
our live stream is pointing out that
modern battles are well documented yes
indeed even even ancient ones are
surprisingly well documented but but one
knows where the battle lines were but
that doesn't you know whether we
consider to that to be the border of the
country is quite unclear to me
anybody want to comment on that we may
have the wrong set of people to discuss
that um I think my main point here is
that we shouldn't forbid having very
precise dates you just have to do the
best we can with the dates I understand
that but what I'm saying is if you've
got a I see you're saying that the date
intervals endpoint could be a day yeah
here's the case that I knew there was a
case I was thinking about okay the the
date intervals endpoint is a day
oh hey this doesn't happen I'm thinking
the next state intervals is it's just a
granule a year but maybe that wouldn't
happen I mean in other words I can
imagine a case where we know something
very particular where we've got the data
so that and then my question is what
does it look like when there is a date
interval which is a year preceded by a
date interval which ends on a day what
does it do my suggestion would be we
assume that we are going to be covering
the time axis and we just mark the
borders in the most precise date we are
fair enough so in other words the if if
the value is you know if it's a for the
thing that ends on January 31st and it's
B for the thing that covers the whole
year then until January 31st it's a and
for the rest of the year it's B so
effectively the B start date is January
31st plus Epsilon right and that will be
a part of probably a function that will
normalize this dating service to make
them a continuous single okay but that's
why I'm saying do we need a date
conformance function that is exposed
which would turn that into that the B
date interval actually starts January
31st plus epsilon rather than the B date
interval just is the granular yeah to
get what I'm saying I don't know what do
we need it but go ahead yeah that will
be useful at least internally but
internally for sure I just don't know
well that needs to be exposed okay fine
conform dates function sort of along the
lines of I think it's conformed images
where you know you can have various
calendars various time zones various
granularities you may want to say I want
these all to be easily comparable dates
and we could have a good idea let's do
it because I think the conformed images
thing is is very much
oops you know conformed images makes
them the same size and so on
or compatible so that the the access are
so all have the same number of rows or
columns but you know I mean conform
dates I like your point about different
calendars and so on seems very relevant
and we could give a second argument to
conform dates that is um specification
yeah right and for example of
granularity specification I mean I could
imagine that you would want to conform
dates where even though some of them you
know to the day you want to conform the
wall to be years
anyway okay that's a that's a separate
thing so let's keep going here to
talking about the event identify in
these things which I think is what we're
talking about here right um that way
that was what we're talking about here
the temporal lookup function down here
that correct do I have a Dropbox
location for this stuff in your
historical data folder thank you
okay so I'm sorry the other unsolved
problem was the estimated distribution
business right
right but I wonder if let should be
discussed by the duration team so
because that will be the output of of
this new function or the same something
with extra arguments I'm sorry which one
a duration no I said oh yeah okay but
wait a minute I'm talking about the
thing where we're saying estimated
distribution of the polygons in a time
series
anyway I'm Kirikou distribution sorry
empirical distraction yes yes I mean so
in Francisco's point is that it's just a
matter of weights so we might not need
empirical distribution
did they taste right so might be a
simpler solution for that but how would
you get that out of the time series well
so um one thing that's I talk to you the
image processing team and audio and they
have a function which is called audio
intervals and I think this is maybe
something that could be used in time
series but I haven't you know so what is
that oh it's each gives you the
intervals for the certain condition on
audio and this is very specific to audio
because it's about the audio and you
know inaudible and and such but what it
returns is actually interval when this
condition is satisfied right so this is
this is what then the the weights that
you would need are the durations of such
intervals so from this you can for
example say that audio was inaudible
during this time and so you could
compute that that's kind of weird I mean
that that's a date intervals it's not
really date it's so in a way it's
temporal intervals when you think about
time series because we know not only
have dates we might have you know reels
orders reels also as a time stamps in a
way that's that's with time proposal
would be temporal intervals something of
that
yes of similar fashion that has a time
series and has a criterion and criterion
that depends on the values right so
that's a value cred mm-hmm so what that
really is
it's more like temporal positions I mean
that would be another name for them it's
like position
right um yes well yes musicians okay now
notice this is about to be very similar
to an event identify function it's very
similar type right you're not so sure
because somehow well that idea of state
intervals is somehow the the reverse of
the thing we were talking about
converting the date intervals into a
time series which might be useful also
under some other circumstances okay so
wait a minute there's another case which
is okay so in it there's time series of
okay so here's an interesting as to what
happens if I just do if I just have a
bunch of dates and I say um let's say
well let's say table well it's a date
day range I can do that right now how
does that work you just give it a start
date and end date and it all
by default give you one day in between
them okay so now if I feed that into
time series what will it do well if you
give just one input it treats them as
values and then automatically assigns
the timestamps so if you just give dates
it's gonna treat them as values and then
it's not wrong I think no I mean that
why wait wait why what would you would
like to be values for that case one and
zero well then it has to be the range
that was created with dominance that we
have values and we would like to
enumerate them that was the I know but
if these things are dates they are not
meaningfully you know you could
distinguish a date from a plausible
value I may also want to have dates as
values no I understand that but then you
know so it's it's it's this is really a
hard decision
you cannot just say this is too
ambiguous to decide automatically so the
decision was made that if you just give
one input is treated as values and and
timestamps are unclear that's right but
I mean in in you you were asking how do
we let's see what am I trying to say the
somebody was saying given a bunch of
data intervals yes the reason we want a
time series out of a bunch of data
intervals is to be able to do things
like determine whether you're on or off
a date interval so to speak so you know
given a list of data intervals you know
is a given time in any of these
intervals or not see what I'm saying now
how would we determine that
but now I mean if we gave a bunch of
data intervals so maybe that's just what
should happen interval member Q should
work on data intervals yeah I think my
thinking right now is that interval
memory queue interval intersection and
interval Union should reasonably work
with date interval they don't have a
meaningful operation with that head
right now and then the relationship for
how do we deal with overlapping cases is
when we look at things like date within
queue and date overlaps queue there's
the question of I have an interval and
then I ask whether this particular date
falls inside it and it falls partway
inside it the distinction between
overlapping and within is helpful yes I
understand but Dave within Q should be
able to take a list of data intervals as
well shouldn't it yeah I think it could
I mean why not give that a list of date
intervals would you want then a list of
boolean values returned or would you
like a single value returned and to say
is this date a member of any of these
intervals I think it's a member of any
of them but how would you combine the
data intervals into a single date but
that that really works over lists
because if it's affecting me doing outer
like you're weeding goom's dozen all
right okay fine
so it can't okay fine but but let me ask
this question then so how do i that's
similar to your time group concept
josè to combine that bunch of data
intervals into a single blob it's a
little weird I don't think that's right
cuz I think you you want something I
think you wants a thing which is a
disjoint x you know look what you want
is a we don't have a date span do we or
date rather than date interval what
would we be this called um it's not a
date object it's a date well that's it
is a date object I mean it's something
like a date group
so in the last last time we discussed
that interval who was what we were
wondering whether to have a multi
interval notation like interval itself
does and then we could combine yeah then
we could combine them just fine
then all we would do is we would say
date interval of the interval objects
and one and two and then we get a single
I this is sounding like a better idea
that that combines into a multi interval
yeah I think so
and it's standardized the granularity
between them if they were disparate but
we need to do that anyway why would we
have to standardize hey we basically you
know we'd have to look at the the
smallest resolution for the
granularities to be able to determine
the appropriate end points but if you
gave a year you know the no but what if
it's what if it's these three days mm-hm
and then a bunch of years in the future
so you know I don't think you want to
more finely granular years they're
disjoint it's okay for that to have them
non-conforming yeah I was talking about
the so we talked two meetings ago about
the the interval itself can also
potentially have a granularity okay fine
and it said I got that right I
understand but yeah the the individual
points can have whatever granularity is
appropriate hey let me ask you another
question
we were whatever happened to the geo
path with a time series geo time series
or whatever it is you know the voyages
of Captain Cook
for example you know he went to Tahiti
on this day that type of thing I think
you are referring to a concept of idea
what we were calling dear trajectory
perhaps yes what happened to Jo
trajectory that's being worked on okay
so how does that relate to any of these
other things so geo trajectory so we've
got a time series of geo points what is
the relationship between geo trajectory
and a time series of geo points okay so
now let me be more awkward what about a
time series of geo polygons is that a
geo trajectory was that we would way we
would be able to get the velocity vector
and acceleration thinks of that okay
let's let me ask the question again I
mean somehow I'm thinking of somehow I'm
reminded of string theory here because
it's like you know one thing is the
world line right of a single point in in
space-time and the other is a world
sheet of some kind or a generalized
pea-brain object so to speak if that
makes sense so the question is can a geo
trajectory sort of define why can't a
geo trajectory define the space-time
tube of a polygon these type of things
typically have a very well-defined
dimensionality and and that allows us to
have properties very specific properties
we are not missing your path and your
polygon so why should yeah I understand
okay so geo trajectory has to be
one-dimensional so it's the geo point
with respect to time you climb which
would allow it so what happens what is
the velocity then so how do you take the
derivative
it will be a it will be something that
we can query with another pair of
rockets and we can say velocity at this
moment okay what does that come back as
some geo bearing type thing says your
vector that tells you at this position
at this time it has this velocity and
what how does the pure back to get units
units units oh is that right oh so jiffy
yeah that's right because if it's a wind
speed or something and has a IC
magnitude m and bearing alpha so the
magnitude M can have a speed I see so so
okay so what does it look like to get
the derivative of the giro trajectory
you're saying that you would expect it
to be just something like I mean okay so
hold on so it's a geo trajectory blah
blah blah of velocity for example okay
is there an analogous thing so it's like
an empirical wouldn't it be useful in in
the general I mean you just have a bunch
of points in space for example so you
have a time series but my question is
how do you get the derivative of a time
series
you get the rate of change we must have
this how do you get given a time series
how do you find the rate of change of
the value in the time series we
differentiate a time series yeah it's
not that sort of function formally you
could think about the path function as a
function and then work with that or you
could just look at you know in the in
the form of approximation of differences
you know and have the quotients between
the values and times thumbs I think
about that yeah difference work already
maybe that's the point that differential
do something sensible with time series
it's no different to set or differences
differences which is a function that
takes a list right it's not differences
is for a list of discrete values because
time series has interpolation inside it
so something to get the predicted
function of the width derivative of time
series so if you do the the you know the
puff function from the time series then
it's interpolating function and then you
can work with that
okay play derivative one to that to see
if it works
well it's give it time I mean I don't
know that's it let's just take a look at
that thing at the point six point seven
very nice okay so we could make
derivative time series work okay
but now geo trajectory then okay but
this tube concept we don't yet have
right that's a time series of geo
polygons I mean this is equivalent to if
I'm not mistaken a time series of
positions okay
but in the case of these tubes where
it's by the way with geo trajectory we
should get some nice things for the data
repository like the voyages of Captain
Cook and so on
but to just to I understand in the case
of those voyages right you know he went
to well I think he ended up in Tahiti
and had a bad experience there um let's
see I'm you know Stan I'm worrying about
how you'd actually give that data um the
I was expected dates are old so this
seems to be the actual thing and
presumably I see presumably they just
took that in this particular case they
just have values that were the geo
position at you know they did some Star
sighting or something every hour or
something and they knew where they were
right right and then for us then our geo
trajectory then we feed that into geo
trajectory GOG tread trajectory has an
interpolation order presumably does it
and then that would that would be that
how that works fine okay O'Brien our
live stream is talking about general
purpose my pencil discussed your
polygons with such a time series yeah
migrations floods etcetera
um yeah I mean the fact is what we have
on the earth right now is geo vector
field like that we have that we have an
ocean that's to statement no what about
the fields okay but he asked a simple
question the gridded population data for
the earth how do we do that do we have a
notion of a geo density function that's
not a concept we're working on this has
consequences for concept I mean it's
basically a geo interpolation yes
then one could imagine the Geo vector in
Revelation well the true statement is
that so I mean in other words the wind
madanpal would be a geo vector
interpolation I see but but we need some
kind of special interpolation function
yes but not not and immediate pipeline
but it's the interpolation it's for you
know models of like fields models so
imagine that you have two points at
which you measure temperature and would
like to know the values between right in
okay it's kind of sense let's go back to
the table lookup okay okay all right so
the first question is a and the question
of event identify like today it's worse
or just right now okay fine
um the so I'm asking about this event
identify thing so the concept of okay so
event identify which i think is a
horrible name um
no go ahead
we were wondering if this event I and if
I who really be lets say an implicit
entity class with extended support for
what you could can do with the unity
glasses really so if you will make more
sense to actually expand entity class to
to these time manipulation instead of
having haven't identified well the
problem is that I think if we have a
vent to identify we're going to need
event within queue and all kinds of
stuff like that but for example this
date we think you is that three that so
it again what they did we think you
isn't that I really not so so okay so
date within queue could be an entity and
then a time okay
so that will tell us okay so that tells
us one thing that tells us okay fine
but then we need to know geo identify so
here's a possibility
okay that we do something with geo
identify that involves dated maybe too
crazy okay so one
Rorty here is let's say you want to say
well you clearly should be able to say
and I think we already discussed this
what country was at this point at this
time right so if I say to identify
country right but if I then say geo
identify dated of country uh 1066 that
should return nothing well it should
return that it should say didn't you
know missing or whatever else that makes
sense sure that's what we already
discussed it listening okay fine so the
question was for for things that didn't
have any geographical correlation or
when you wanted to do some kind of query
dinging yes that is basically I mean so
it's not it's not a data identifiers
because it's not the well it is kind of
a date identify yeah like go ahead I
think they call that event because so
you are not returning the date you're
returning asking an entity or something
that's right but but the fact that we're
calling these events we're not
officially calling them events so what
is the objects so they will contain
dates well will it return an object that
several question that's part of this
question okay so hold on so then okay so
we've also got geo nearest so we could
imagine a date nearest as well analogous
to June nearest and as we've talked
about previously we want understand that
but not with not with dates relative to
the you know knowledge base right that's
the way we were wondering if we should
improve the entity this identity classes
to actually support this data to look up
this date lookups better I think there
will be nice parametric that gets us off
the hook for these other things I think
we should look at that example they have
the president of the u.s. so for example
this event identified should be Donald
Trump at this time
because those dates those queries always
amorphous I'm right but that's an
incredibly weird input here you know
this government position
boy that's a really weird thing that
we're returning there right it's not
just an event in this case that's
returning so there are two things this
is a G oh boy this is weird so one case
of this event identify is forget the
Germany it's just what military
conflicts were there
wait a second so one possibility would
be identified to identify holiday okay
what holidays are going on right now
that make sense so that's a pure time
thing that that's okay that goes to
essentially worldwide holidays today
that right right
whereas ident event identify holiday um
Belgium should give so the second
argument is kind of the Geo bounds of
the event
should should we maybe use restricted as
it is a really use it in the interpreter
so to use restricted our apparel quality
yeah we could I suppose it's a little
weird okay so you're saying restricted
holiday and then Belgium for example
right which I think that's not really
possible indeed that's a real documented
in restricted sure but see this event
identifies really weird I mean maybe the
general case is entity identify yeah and
that's why we I was also saying that
maybe instead of creating this event
identify will be better - if entity
classes have better support for all
these state stuff I think we need
examples that are not G overrated at all
not ready to country police are also
yeah okay clips is the less related to
countries okay so what are some things
that are I mean eclipses full moon
yeah right which we just wanted a
function we just added a function to
compute the next full moon okay but
that's it that's a similar thing when is
the next full moon when is the full moon
nearest to such and such a time hump
okay okay
general case of this so the general case
as you say you can do this with entity
class what will we have to extend to
entity class extend with entity clause
you say for only the support for example
for nearest a date so we go search for
start there is an example yeah so so
maybe that's a way to do this nearest
Tony here or anybody representing the
entity framework folk no I mean we have
to all you have to ask them about this
but it would be nice you know if what
you want to know is who was the US
president in 1800 right you don't want
to go through some weird thing with with
implicit entities I don't think yes yes
then after we have the extension support
for entity classes we can sync on
whether a convenience function that we
did say unravel all these entity classes
parameters right but but let's think
about that right now because I mean
basically what we want is okay so what
are the parameters here there's the type
of thing one's looking for there's the
and then there's the space-time interval
basically today and you know region geo
region if there is one now the case of a
Geo region but no date is already
covered in geo identify right yeah right
so Jill region with a date is also
covered in geo identify yeah that's the
extension we want like although this
thing about this president thing is
pretty weird I mean so we would end up
saying geo identify now that's just
totally weird because that's what I said
here is the type of thing one's looking
for this isn't a type of thing this is a
single entity
I don't understand that one at all
so why when we have an entity class of
presidents or even an entity domain so
if if that was the case we would put it
there so this feels like we have an
entity which is playing the role of our
four tight you know it's a discussion
for the entity people but I agree that
that's a that doesn't seem to make sense
there okay but so this is okay so the
goal is and the goal here is find things
of that type it's an entity search it is
I mean the find
anything is being done by implicit
entities elsewhere yep maybe that there
a difference within with some kind of
more general entity search that may want
to search among different entity types
which is what you identified us so it
may search at the same time between
admissions poetry set so that's what
entity class doesn't matter because it's
always that's a type right so the
question is do we need a find entities
function
I mean to me event identify is just not
gonna make it because they're just not
events but something like a dated
identify it's a weird name weird name
but again it always returns entities
right I find entities classes is going
to be enough because in order to make it
powerful we need to insert operators
there and so we times we go to
discussion of which operators we would
need okay so if we had dated identify
and dated nearest then the way they
would work we'd say dated identify and
then the simplest case would be an
entity type and what that's doing is
it's effectively finding I mean it is
converting itself into an entity class
query um
that and then dated identify would also
have a Geo possibility I don't know what
happens a fee I see so that's
which of these instances of the entity
type exists at which instances of the
answer to type exist during those dates
unless then the question of whether
there's a
then q and so on and so on and so on I
mean then the question is to state
within q end up taking a type a time and
a Geo I think if it's the three
arguments then we can do it with you
even though perhaps it's nicer expressed
sorry that's what I meant
no wait a minute date with NQ I see
chill you're suggesting that that would
be geo within Q but the problem is I see
if it needs the three arguments you
could do with your with NQ yes though it
may be nicer this way because it's more
important time is more important than
you yeah also in the date identify with
G elements that somehow what we are now
at something they give it in fact
they're proving is that probably there's
a position so the holidays hopefully we
don't have a position but we have a
geo-referenced which is the country so
that's a different type of entity so
it's not that well yeah I do anything
this and that it doesn't have a position
but he has your graphical reference
which is well I mean we could certainly
do if we did something like geo identify
country and we could say all what will
happen if I do that okay
so that could mean if I'm not mistaken
that could mean countries in the whole
world that could be an entity list of
countries and probably should be alright
because if I say geo identify country
you know North America why is this so
slow why is this so slow
and it is what we are also extending how
to call these in the new seven well okay
but this is what is it doing
what's it doing what's going on I mean
this will presumably return a result
what come on what's happening here yeah
what it is that it should return the
list of countries that's right right but
then this first one here could perfectly
well return all of them and so if geo
identify
a third argument that was the time then
in a sense the only issue is the offer
goodness frigging sake well okay that's
a bug okay but then so then what we're
saying is that date identify yeah I mean
the fact is tells apart
data identifying geo identify are
analogous I claim yes and the case we
thought the geo is important yes when
you don't have an actual volume or your
position for that interview like for
example colleagues
police might have a country reference
but not a position but you also want you
look just in terms of the semantics of
what's going on data identify of
military conflicts comma 1945
you know what military conflicts were
going on in 1945 right that's possible
way to express that for example a query
could be all the normal prices of this
year and that something known gee sure
and so then they
identify would say what things I mean
animagic one could imagine okay one
could imagine that data identify as well
as geo identify could take not an entity
type so that one possibility is entity
type here oh yeah look at this look at
this look at this look at this okay so
so let's try this cheer identify and
then let's say okay so let's say members
of world meteorological organization
okay so now watch this for coolness if
it worked
but you probably won't so let's say I
say that and then I say Europe that
gonna work I think the problem is that
you identify is prepared for points in
the second argument so this is probably
going to there to your server and trying
to do that for all points of Europe
which is a huge combination okay so fine
so that's a bug but semantically this
could make sense this is saying this is
saying so this would allow an entity
classes so for example for presidents so
long as we have an entity class of
presidents like we might even have right
now an entity class of US presidents not
a good sign
well whatever week so this would make
sense this is a way of doing what you
want here namely geo identify of entity
class region will give you those
instances that lie within that region
right similarly date identify of an
entity class like presidents comma a
date 1850 or something we'll give you
all members of that entity class that
lie within that date range
I like the sir
is going to work I've got some plumbing
to figure out but I think it's gonna
work make sense all right next time okay
so let's think about this a little bit
more but then we've got yet more to
discuss here I mean there's people theta
thing I mean sorry leaders needs to be
discussed - what is this we already
addressed this question well for leader
theta integration which is a wolf in
language we haven't you we need to
define where we had a find right now on
alpha that our leader is the
intersection of jurisdiction type of
position and a person but we don't think
that it can be easily converted into
language I'm sorry
position time and jurisdiction you're
saying the three things that you're
intersecting right now all right
you said position time a jurisdiction
like you know vice
of andorra
in 1960 that what we mean by that did I
lose you all hello can you hear me hear
you and I believe it's like he meant
okay so the issue is something to do
with the way that entities are
represented and the fact that we can't
have that kind of triple in the NAND
city because we have the notion of dated
but we don't have a notion of geode
right so the question was if we want
these kind of what will be the best way
to represent the entities we will have
this triplet in the name of course that
if there is a better way to I would have
thought an association but I don't know
whether we do that at all this is a
question Tony needs to be here for this
discussion this is his kind of thing
yeah okay well we have made progress so
let's try and think through all these
all these things here but I think we've
got a good thing going with this all
right
um great okay thanks all see you soon
thanks everyone okay bye thanks